okay me I've got stuff and I'm running
out of places to put it
sorry everybody give me a minute okay
I'm gonna do that gonna shift this I'm
gonna grab there we go hey everybody
so yeah huh
40,000 subscribers that like
legitimately that is very very very cool
the this year has had much slower growth
for me than last year and it slowed
pretty early in the year and so by about
May I had given up on the idea of
breaking 30,000 in this calendar year so
this is legitimately a nice surprised so
um that doesn't mean a couple things it
means that I am doing this as a QA found
your panel this year cool thank you
biscuits so a couple of ground rules for
this QA no questions that boil down to
have you seen X or what did you think of
X because my opinions on various pieces
of media is what literally the entire
rest of the channel is and it's also
what the live streams tend to end up
becoming on their own anyways and I want
this one to be different so whatever
questions you intend to ask
they can't be either of those things
that's rule number one
rule number two I don't make promises
about answering any questions unless two
things one is coming from the discord
which I'll check later in the live
stream and two
and like I'm sorry to make this a hard
rule unless it's done as a super chat
that's not me saying I'm going to ignore
questions that aren't done that way just
how to make no promises of getting to
them if they aren't and also just to
make this one fun I do have I have water
it's peppermint schnapps I'm not gonna
hold up the thing and I am willing to
take a shot for any super chat of five
dollars or more so at that as an
incentive yes I am trying to pull in a
little extra financing before the end of
the year it's been a rough one at a lot
of ways but so those are our ground
rules on that
mazelTov are getting so many subs thank
you who would you want is your
grandfather out of the twelfth doctor or
grandma Brian I mean the twelfth doctor
actually reminds me a little bit of my
actual grandfather that sort of adorably
grumpy so probably go that way for a
nostalgic reasons would you ever have
Liz on a live stream I'd be happy to
have Liz on a live stream the logistics
are make it very unlikely as it
currently stands but it's a possibility
I'm open to it okay seriously what were
you doing with those flowers on
Instagram if anyone who follows me on
Instagram
ooh geez okay so uh Thank You Tracy
we'll get I'll get the poor ring that I
have liquid luck so if you follow me on
Instagram it's at very wild I don't have
that Council of geeks which does exist
but somebody else has it I posted
pictures from my last burlesque show
which was this past Friday and I I
posted pictures I did two numbers but I
posted pictures from a bridal number
that I did so me and not really a
wedding dress but in items approximating
a wedding dress and there
out of me in a chair likes played with
the with a bouquet right there so I'm
not going to answer that question as to
what was I doing but that's an
explanation for anyone who missed it
cheers Tracy this has the potential to
be a very interesting evening we will
see how this goes
who and yes I am doing shops which is on
the weaker side and that's as a safety
net for myself
because like the only other thing I had
that was really suitable was 90 proof
rum and that would have been a bad idea
okay uh good luck with the knife oh boy
uh maybe I'll stay up for this six hours
sleep isn't bad right actually six hours
is not far from my standard I try to be
in bed by midnight and my alarm goes off
at 6:30 so you know accounting for
falling asleep time six hours is about
what I get would you rather see Jon
Pertwee return as the doctor or Roger
Delgado return as the master if I could
only have one I would have Delgado as
the master perfectly was was really good
though remember a couple weeks back when
I said I saw I was going to re-watch
evolution of the Daleks because I loved
it as a kid oh god the tentacles why yes
seriously those things like the design
isn't great but they're like so
mechanical like if you're gonna do
tentacles they gotta have a fluidity to
the movement otherwise it's just oh it's
painful if 13 got a new companion them
on their own with 13 and no fam what
would you want he/she to be like noting
there would be only one question that's
not I don't really have an answer cuz
that's not anything that I've thought
about again that it has to do with part
of part of my tendency to not project
too hard specific yeah about specifics
of what I want things I like like Doctor
Who or Star Wars or the MCU to do
because then you then you have the trap
of well I wanted them to do this
specific thing and they didn't I do take
that things that I hope they don't do
but that means that as long as they
don't do those
things almost anything else they do
might work for me it's don't like knob
but it won't automatically annoy me so
because my headspace doesn't work that
way I'm not sure I'm actually equipped
to answer that is there anything you'd
go back and study given a chance
um I'm I wish that when I was a kid I'd
taken dance instead of karate that
that's a switch I would made if I I
would make if I could sure should 13 get
a new screwdriver design at some point
um this is the best t-shirt ever this
t-shirt is part of my merch and the link
for the merch store down in the
description you can get this multi rar
for different skin tones for the fist
and many color options for this so oh
god oh the sonic screwdriver question so
um I would say since the design of a
screwdriver seems very intrinsically
linked to the interior design of the
TARDIS if the TARDIS gets redesigned
then yes she should get a new
screwdriver if it doesn't I don't think
there's any real reason to do it
oh boy Castiel huh huh huh what changes
would you make for the fantastic beast
series um well the first thing that I
would do is I well in my ideal world
we'd scrap Grindelwald completely and
just have it be the beasts have it be a
smaller story about newt and about the
friendships that he builds and the
adventures that he goes on unfortunately
at this point we're kind of stuck with
dealing with Grindelwald excuse me um at
least in the very next film he's got to
be resolved because he can't leave that
hanging so like I would say you branch
it off into two series you have the
fight for Grindelwald focus on
Dumbledore and Grindelwald and have Newt
go off and do his own thing in a
separate series because I feel like in
crimes are involved especially those two
elements the actual fantastic beasts and
the building towards the showdown
between grinev old and Dumbledore don't
marry very well they feel very shoehorn
together and I feel like integrating
them was kind of one of the big mistakes
of that film and also actually of the
first film it's why I think the third
act doesn't really work at all but uh I
might have made a big mistake here well
see how it goes oh and I also I'm not
gonna scroll back for questions that I
missed especially if I'm drinking um so
if if I missed your question you can ask
it again again but no promises unless
it's done as a super check if you had to
pick one what celebrity would you
resurrect ooh Caroll Spinney that one's
fresh but I'd still do it who do you
think thirteen was talking to on the
phone and the series 12 trailer do you
think Kate Stewart's gonna come back
actually haven't put any thought into
who she was talking to and I'm I go back
and forth on whether or not I want Kate
Stewart back because I liked her at her
inception but subsequent returning of
her I haven't done a lot for me
do you like Mariah Carey and I like all
I want for Christmas alone that it's not
my type of music oh it's your favorite
mythology and favorite portrayal of it
been playing too much Hades recently um
it's not really a proper mythology
because it's not that structured but I'm
fond of sort of Irish Celtic Scottish
folklore um you know will willow the
wisps and the Morrigan and things like
that I'm quite fond of if I were to pick
a favorite I would say the film The
Secret of Kells would be my top pick for
a depiction of that Oh Trent oh how far
are we 10 minutes this was a mistake
sorry if you've covered this in your
videos but new fan here wanting to get
into Doctor Who where should I start
grats on the milestone well okay the
multiple multiple parts to this answer
uh if you are already intent to get in
it then you don't have to do what
normally advice cuz what I advise people
to do if they want to try and get
someone who has no particular interest
in Doctor Who to at least give it a shot
is to show them blink but you don't
continue on from blink so if you're
already interested in seeing you we can
skip that step and to my way of thinking
there are three jumping on points that I
think work the best and I'll actually
sort of name them in descending order of
how well I think they work as jumping on
points and what I say jumping on I don't
mean because some of these are further
into the new series than just the
beginning of it
because young with the intent being you
start there and then go forward from
there and then flip back and like catch
up or even like once you're into it go
back and catch up
I think series 5 is in my opinion the
best starting point you point if you're
already really interested in getting
into the show then after that I would
actually say series 10 which might sound
odd because it was the last series for
Capaldi and the last series for Moffat
but it really has a solid jumping on
point even though it has some callbacks
I it works as a starting point so at the
bottom of that list I would put series 1
I don't strongly recommend starting at
series 1 unless you are already
committed to powering through and so
like that's why I say start elsewhere to
get into it and then go back to series 1
not that series 1 is bad it's just
series 1 it has a lot of stuff in it
that is not indicative of what the show
is after that they were things they try
it out early on but they dropped a lot
of that being some of the goofier
aspects of it some of the more campy
elements they dropped off and the show
took us all a bit more seriously after
that and you would think well you start
with series 2 then except series two
builds so directly after series 1 but
I'm not sure it works as a place to
start so my recommendation is series 5
series 10 works if you are prepared to
power through some stuff that is not
representative of how the show is going
to remain you can start at series 1 I
just kind of put an asterisks on that
one
that was a prolonged explanation and
whoo I can still pour it cleanly so
that's a good sign
oh boy um should the Slitheen come back
I uh I don't know what there is left to
do with them at this point
um I don't want to say you know hard no
on that but I don't know it just I I
just don't know what there is to do
other than have it just be a straight
nostalgic call back and speaking
personally something I'm not especially
a nostalgic for so how would you play
the master um so like as a character um
if if I were cast as the master
broad-strokes is hard to say like I I've
said I kind of want the a go I'd go more
quiet I go more quiet malevolence on it
because we kind of had the more
bombastic a little bit more over the top
a little bit more camp we had both John
Simm and with Michelle Gomez um and in
the case of Missy I really liked her but
I think it's time to go the other way
and to go more sort of seeding intensity
we did we did the fawn master let's
bring back the scary master ok moving
any tips for getting subscribers I've
had five so far unfortunately I honestly
don't i I've been doing this for a while
now I think I'm in my eighth year of
doing this um so I don't know what the
landscape is like starting out anymore
I'm just not a good person to ask for
that and honestly anyone who's been on
this platform and
especially anyone who's had more than a
thousand subscribers for I would say
more than two years
any advice they give you is gonna be at
best out-of-date because the platform
has changed so much that I'd honestly
don't know I mean my standard advice
still applies do what you love and be
sure that it's something that you want
to do regardless of whether or not
someone is watching because that'll keep
you going even if you're not growing but
in terms of like how do I get more
subscribers at this point I honestly
don't know
especially from up from like starting
from the ground level that may sound
contradictory given that I just launched
the the breakroom of geeks so like I
technically started a new channel but
all I had to do was plug it here and it
jumped up over a thousand subscribers
within a month after that so I you know
I had an advantage in doing that um we
got here oh geez okay um what historical
figures would you like the doctor to
meet my top picks are Alfred Hitchcock
dawn of Arc and Helen Keller Helen
Keller will be interesting Joan of Arc I
think that would be a tough one to do
without excessive mythologizing of the
of the historical figure which is
usually one of my reservations about
those stories in the first place
I might start not going quite so close
up to the line on this forgive me
as far as Alfred Hitchcock maybe I
here's the I'd be curious to see what
kind of story you build around that as
far as like him as a person I don't know
I think he's too easy to do in a
caricature style if I were gonna pick
someone hmm
oh boy I'm kind of drawing a blank right
now um yeah no I am absolutely drawing a
blank because I I kind of want I want
the doctor to meet more people who are
important
but not well-known I'm kind of over
celebrity historical figures you know
one like oh I know who that is and I
would like to see more that are like oh
I like maybe heard of that but I don't
know a ton about it
I'd like to see that come up a bit more
um but I don't have an example off the
top of my head that I like and think to
cite for that probably because my brain
is at this point becoming increasingly
muddled Oh God oh dear oh dear oh dear
do you plan to update your top doctors
list with a thirteenth doctor not until
she's finished her run at that point I
will but not before them because I've
learned with Capaldi that my opinion of
a doctor can change over the course of
their run so I don't want to place her
on that list until she has left the part
because I feel like it's not being fair
to her otherwise and I'm not saying no
one else can place her on a list I'm
just saying for me learning from my
experience of having my opinion of a
doctor change while the show is airing
that's how I'm approaching it do you
have an outfit for 12 when you get to
his reviews will you be doing over to
dr. who really reviews I don't yet I'm
looking into that and yes given that
enough time has passed since come houses
run that even though I have actually
reviewed those already I do intend to
keep it going it'll probably it'll
become Doctor Who take 2 reviews or
someone young like that if two things
cross over what would you like them to
be personally I would love Doctor Who
and Rick and Morty I'm not huge fan of
Rick and Morty um I
oh it's funny I did a I did a video ages
ago with Ryan about like movie mashups
that we wanted to see I think the pitch
that I had that I was the most excited
by was the idea of
ghostbusters teaming up with ash from
army of the Dead to fight the ring
Samara and from the ring movies that was
like the the concept I was happiest with
I would have a question I'm just trying
to get you pissed up seriously though we
enjoy your content good work
oh god you you folks you are killing me
thanks for that I answer actually did
help oh well good
that's good to hear oh boy so close to
the top and that that is not what
happened oh boy oh god oh jeez I might
need to slow down I'm not so I'm first
of all let's backtrack I'm reserving the
right to stop if I feel that I need to
stop but um at right now uh-huh
I'm going to if another one comes right
away I'm going to like take a little bit
of time before I get to it so I do still
have work in the morning oh don't make
yourself sick um that's that's why I'm
setting these things oh my god I just
had a hilarious idea what if the fam
swap bodies in an episode ah I don't
know man I feel like body swapping is
really a staple a fantasy sci-fi shows
any fantasy sci-fi show that goes long
enough eventually does a body swapping
episode or at least the ones that I've
seen you know Buffy did it Farscape did
it pretty sure star trek various Star
Trek's have done it uh it just feels
like a very standard sci-fi fantasy
thing to do eventually that I kind of
would rather they didn't maybe that's me
you totally skip my $5 super tat oh crap
I was only saying congratulations but
that kind of I'm just
sorry Tiffany I probably started
rambling on on other stuff and missed it
okay all right I'm I'm legitimately
sorry Tiffany because I am trying to
stay by my word on this and I am okay
all right that that's a bit more
reasonable Oh which I do for my 22nd
birthday tomorrow
well tomorrow's a Wednesday so I would
say go get for schnockered but given
that it's a Wednesday I'm gonna advise
against that
scooby-doo live action films do you like
them I've never seen either one in their
entirety I've only seen bits and pieces
so no opinion and also not a huge
scooby-doo fan so not something I'd
super have an opinion on either way have
you heard of mixers I have therefore
whims besides most mixers you know you
make a drink I mean you just put in the
equivalent of a shot into them anyway so
Oh Traci you killing me I don't mind I
love you what was the book movie show
that sparked your love of sci-fi no need
to take a shot okay I'm taking that as
an exemption thank you um I couldn't
actually tell you because I have been
into sci-fi for as long as I can
remember because you need to realize I I
do not remember watching Star Wars for
the first time
I don't remember watching Star Trek for
the voyage home for the first time
that's how long they've been part of my
life that's how intrinsic they have been
to my growing up so I can't even tell
you what started my little of sci-fi
because as far as my memory is concerned
I have always had it that's $10 isn't
that two shots not one I did not say
that I would take a shot for every $5 I
said I would take a shot for every Super
pledge of that
least five dollars not that I would take
a shot for every $5 increment try but I
did cover my butt you can backtrack and
check the tape on that which old
companion would have the biggest reason
2:13 I'm not sure what you mean by
reason Martha I would think um I mean if
I would just to think of a past campaign
who I'd like to see meet 13 it's kind of
selfishly I want to say River Song cuz I
just want to see her face um oh no
something else that I can do I got a
couple of packages from folks that I'm
pretty sure we're bought off my which
list it's inappropriate to address your
poise as whips based on their drinking
preferences I'm sorry Jo oh [ __ ] sorry
who knock daddy wouldn't take smooth I
like mixers it's nothing wrong with them
I was just I'm just I'm not in a 100%
state of mind at this point
so yeah anyway wish list not which list
Meg mm Meg you're gonna get it um okay
anyways I've got a couple of things I
actually don't know what's in them I did
they have been open so it looks like you
know what's in them but I only opened
them to like get us that like to reach
in and see if I could find a gift
receipt and or like check to see if it
look like something that I had ordered
cuz I still got things that I ordered
for Christmas for people coming in so I
go I don't know what is in hey how are
you not sober that's how I am so first
thing I have on suspicion what this is
now also I should stress before I open
any of these I have not gotten to peel
box in about a week
and I need to cuz I know at least a few
people who have sent me stuff through
there Oh God okay
paxil was I I will come back to that I
promise just give me a minute
um so I haven't gotten to the pol box so
that's why I'm pretty sure this stuff is
on my wish list cuz when you order my
wish list it comes straight to my house
so we're gonna see what we got here I
like the shape on this already there's
only a couple of things that good okay
here we go and that my friends that is a
rainbow loom umbrella haha that makes me
happy I'm not opening it indoors I know
bad luck not that far gone alright let's
see what else we got
I'm coming back to that that $14.99
pounds which I could learn conversion
let's see what else we got here oh hey
Tracy
this one's from you don't fake oh I
should check they're good for seeing
that one this one also from Tracy oh my
god like I would tell you to stop
spending so much money on me except
don't stop spending so much money on me
what do we get oh nice
I did have had this on my wish list for
a while so Justice League gods and
monsters this one like I really hold up
because I'm kind of over the DC animated
movies being based off of existing
graphic novels or store or comic book
storylines and I really I hold this one
up because this was an original story
for the animated film and I wish they
would do this more is this is great I
would say I need your beauty except I've
already done that one don't worry I just
tossed it onto the bed it's fine um I I
really wish they they would do this
stuff more Han but I've already done a
review on that so I don't need to redo
it but man that was ages ago cuz I still
have the green screen
Wow okay I've got one more package all
right okay oh let's see
a gift for you Tracy these are all from
you which Doctor Who stories a guilty
pleasure story for you for me it's
evolution of the Daleks now um I need to
re-watch it it's been a little while but
the closest to a guilty pleasure is
probably robots of Sherwood because I'm
not sure if it's good but I love the
banter so much cut it open with a cat
with a something or Crotona I'm not with
a what with a Jan I don't even know what
that is
I don't know I don't know what that is
nor do I know if I have that I love
getting these because I can Rio I'm not
gonna reuse that one though that's been
slithering coerced
oh that's nice so this this you actually
I meant to move this off the standard
which list this is actually something
that I put on there to keep track of cuz
it's for my daughter for Christmas I
can't remember if I ordered one as well
that's really thank you though
oh I'm a dope and let's see okay
whoa oh nice oh because I needed more
hoodies in my life and I'm gonna put it
on well I read the question that I have
to take a shot for very much enjoy your
videos so nah that's all I'm flinging
some Daksh at you sorry it isn't more
but the gardening work is about to dry
up for a couple of months thoughts on
expanse no shot needed um I might take
the shot anyway
no I'll pause a pause on the drink cuz
it's it's we're barely halfway through
this live stream oh oh oh that fits nice
hmm umm I still haven't seen the expanse
I've heard really good things about it
but um I have not seen it yet so I
actually am not in a position to answer
that started watching the goat start low
sorry started playing the Ghostbusters
video game and oh my god it's extremely
good I have not played that yet I've
heard good things about it and I know
when I put up my what I put up my my
reaction to and my thoughts on the new
Ghostbusters trailer
more than a few people pointed me to
that as being like more or less the
official third Ghostbusters and I still
haven't played it like I mean I've got a
freaking collection of games there are
seldom played so but I have heard good
things about that I put it on my hoodie
Huff oh great
power oh goodness gracious drunken a
hoodie my Christmas wig which has been
granted make you sassy little mm um
currently binge-watching broadchurch for
the first time halfway through season
two at the moment any chance I will see
a continuation of
that review series sometime soon I don't
have plans um to go further on
broadchurch it's the kind of thing that
like I'd come back to if I had free time
but I kind of don't so no plans at yet
okay I could always get Commission to
review it that's a possibility when we
watch Shazam hopefully soon I want to
try and cram it in before the end of the
year so I can figure out whether or not
I'm gonna put it on my top ten of the
Year list so soon I hope yeah I pursue
boy questions are getting away from me
yeah I personally think if River ever
met thirteen she would squeeze her
second wives but at some point I am
sober enough that I know to censor
myself although the fact that I'm
drinking it probably means there's gonna
be demonetised anyway so there you go I
can talk quickly while still iffy ah
[Music]
what's your preferred method of
consuming missing Doctor Who animation
with original audio novelization CDs
with original audio I do like the
animations provided they don't try and
over correct too much like I some has
seen the macro Terra but I've seen bits
and I feel like they cleaned up the the
look of the Macra too much like there's
no way that the original looked that
good and I feel like that's that's a
little bit innocent I like drunks
Nathaniel I like you too pirates people
have been doing the super chat are using
British terms are all the people paying
Hugh British am I being on patriotic or
poor by not doing the same well first of
all if you're an American it's very
patriotic to be poor that's the American
Way it's the majority stance but yeah
like about it's a bottom even split
according to my analytics between US and
UK viewers it's about 30% in both cases
of my my viewing demographic so it's
neck-and-neck viewership wise as far as
donations
super chats do seem to come a little bit
more from the UK so I mean if anyone's
feeling patriotic and wants to show the
Brits what for hey god what's been
thrown um Sherlock will be 10 years old
in 2020 honey if I wasn't doing an
anniversary retrospective that thought
hadn't even occurred to me I mean now
that you've said it and maybe I don't
know how about 13th century Muslim
physician I banal not this I apologize
for butchering that as a Doctor Who
historical he's also written the novel
feel adjusts auto-detect her thing which
was one of the precursors of science
fiction sure that kind of thing I think
would be awesome happy all for that uh
would you be the doctor that had a would
you be the doctor that had a hangover
story
happy Christmas love oh boy I really
hope I don't end up with a hangover out
of curiosity how much of your
demographics is from Australia I don't
know off the top of my head
what are your thoughts on the cast movie
are you excited are you scared are you
both I'm just confused because I've
never understood the the appeal of cats
in the first place so you know what I'm
now curious as to the percentage of my
subscribers that are in Australia I'm
gonna go look let's see audience top
countries 4% so as far as percentage of
my viewers you are fourth place because
it is currently Oh United States has
surged ahead um not this is just based
off the last 28 days obviously this
shifts because especially when Doctor
Who is airing it's much more a 30-30
between the u.s. and the UK at present
within the last 28 days United States
was 39% United Kingdom 24 can they
Canadia haha
Canada 4.2 Australia for Germany 3.8
Germany ha okay
and this is this is turning into an
interesting evening a news publication
soon discovered the increase of UK debt
was enlarged due to continuing funding
into Council of geeks super chats I am
sorry that I screwed up your your
capitalistic system although it probably
screwed itself up before I got here
have you seen the season 12 TARDIS
updates I'm dingy I haven't because I've
been avoiding spoilers like I I watched
the trailers that come out cuz I'm
curious enough for that but like extra
behind the scenes things and a lot of
the rumors I've been trying to avoid so
no I haven't seen that you're acting
strange have you been infected by red
first ones tech oh the sword got
infected but not a Dora herself I guess
she is organic matter
I've been re watching that lately I
might my daughter's now into it my
daughter's she raw I'm so happy um I I
will get to this question a second I'm
drunk on sight her haha have a bit more
carried on make carry on okay I will
pour this while I talked my daughter is
finally into Shira I got her into it
because I explained to her that yes
there's oh jeez I just dropped it yeah
okay
cuz I explained to her that yes there's
fighting in their stores I would but
that's not what really the show is about
that shows about the relationships
between the characters cuz that's what
she she is more into so she's not
watching it she burned through season 1
on her own and I've gotten to our some
season two with her and we very recently
watched that episode the the one set in
the snow where there's it's basically
drunk adora um are you drunk are you
Noel and have a happiness pork and all
those dose my current assumption is that
life is imitating art and the current UK
Parliament is under Slitheen control
that would work but anyways I I have to
I have to share this so on her own
without prompting from me without
nudging without hinting without any of
that when I asked my kid because he told
me she'd she'd finished season one on
her own I asked her what she liked
especially and she said Katra in a
tuxedo I come so proud of my kid that
makes me so happy and like at this point
cuz I showed her I showed her the little
music video thing I did for Skorpio
that's over on the break room and when
ik what I had the clips of cash for the
tux again without prompting for me just
watching it she's watching it goes Katra
in a tux is the best thing ever
as far as catchers no sorry cat relies
so kachra wise heard Nantucket is the
best thing ever
I'm so freaking happy that my kid is
into the show and she's single without
Katra in a tux as something she really
loves ah
buy her something expensive I've bought
her Christmas already
she is covered I shall force you to
remember the race dance cameo in Casper
Oh cruel and for the record that was not
ray Stantz
that was a cosplayer in that universe I
refused to believe that they were
actually connected ah would you
recommend the red dwarf episode
quarantine my absolute favorite as a
blink as test to see if someone will
like the show it worked for me when I
was about six and Quarantine would work
for that marooned would also be a good
test bubble episode four for red dwarf I
feel like I'm surprisingly coherent for
how much I have had to Joe whoa whoa
this was a brand new bottle and I
started
but I could also be completely off about
that I could be slurring my words way
more than I actually am and not
realizing it it's just kinda what
happening that's awesome I bet your
daughter would love the original Danger
Mouse and trapdoor the episode custard
is hilarious she aged it was into the
new Danger Mouse for like a hot minute
but they moved on from other stuff I
don't know if this is bad way to ask
this cuz I'm new at this but would it in
your opinion be hard for Doctor Who to
depict a cross-dressing doctor or excuse
me
non cisgender non-binary etc doctor no I
don't think it would be hard at all all
I have to do is have them visually
present in a gender blended or ambiguous
or androgynous way and literally never
draw attention to it just have it be it
is literally that simple how long does a
guy got to work to achieve the moderator
promotion
Joel I had no idea that you wanted
moderator privileges religious privilege
oh that's a hard word um I need to do is
ask dude seriously how do you talk to
your daughter about your gender identity
and other LGBTQ topics I don't because
that's the thing I've never had a
sit-down conversation with my daughter
about my gender identity cuz I haven't
had to cuz this is her normal she
doesn't need a conversation about it
because this is just who I am to her
I've never hidden this from her that was
something that her mother and I had a
conversation about even before she was
born that this was gonna be presented as
normal and that that was more important
than anything else that she not have to
be told about this that she not have to
rebuild her understanding of
based on finding out about this that
it's her standard it's her normal it is
just her knowing me as I am it's me not
hiding Who I am from her and I never
have she was - and that was the first
time she saw me in full dress now I
don't really do that anymore unless I'm
performing but there was a time when in
order to feel more feminine I would have
to do the full address I'd have to do
full makeup do wigs use breast forms
high heels the works I don't have to do
that anymore to connect with my feminine
side and I'm grateful for that but she
was 2 years old and her mother and I had
her watch me put on the makeup put on
the wig so that I didn't just disappear
and something come back looking
different she saw the process she
understood that it's still me it's still
her father so that and as far as she's
concerned I'm just I'm just her father
she doesn't call me something different
if I even present full feminine my
relationship with her never changes no
matter what my presentation is my
relationship terzi's but actually the
same I am her father
and sometimes I look one way sometimes I
look another and she doesn't blink an
eye because that is how she has grown up
this is her normal okay what do we got
here I love your channel so much I don't
know how I even found it thank you to
get the YouTube algorithm it has treated
me well on occasion but you've got such
fresh interesting content love you thank
you very much and oh boy here we go
yeah imagine if the doctor meant PT
Barnum I will be up for that provided
they did a more accurate representation
of PT Barnum than greatest showman was
and I say that as a fan of greatest
showman I legitimately like that movie
if I'd seen it before the end of the
year it would have been on my top 10 of
the Year list
huh The Simpsons is 30 years old oh I
almost swore at you huh don't tell me
that I think if a river met thirteen she
would try and put 13 a very really
revealing dress and makeup of Ag might
and 13 would stop her and that's why it
would be awesome we know you drank too
much when you start talking like the
cambrics of the racnoss a statistical
discord Oh Thank You Carolyn yes I do
need to check the discord hold on okay
that's not too bad
uh hot take the early seasons of the
Real Ghostbusters cartoon of my favorite
incarnation of the franchise there are
good episodes in the later seasons some
people will tell you that after it
became Slimer in the Real Ghostbusters
none of the episodes were good that's
not true there are so good ones at that
point but it is true most of the really
good ones are from the first season or
first two seasons depending on how you
look at them but ya know the the Sandman
episode is my personal favorite but the
first Psalm Haim SOT Samhain
whatever episode is amazing and I watch
that every year at Halloween it's
phenomenal the early season of the oh I
read that well my 30th is coming up soon
so oh you young uns which doctor would
you want to meet I love 13 and 10 or 13
and 12 see 12 is my favorite right now
but I'm not sure I want to meet him cuz
I think I'd annoy him I probably go with
11 I think we're close enough to the
same the same wavelength that would work
okay Oh what do you do when your
daughter experiences sentiments to the
contrary I'm I feel like I'm missing a
front piece to that because I'm not sure
what you're referring to sentiments to
the contrary of
what and I ask you that hasn't about to
jump over to the discord and jump out of
this so like you've got I'm gonna give
you a minute to respond to that and
clarify the question and I'll try and
pick it up uh the doctor needs to me
Stephen Sondheim haha music ooh Jimi
Hendrix I'd be down for that I'm off to
a marathon screening of the complete
Star Wars sequel trilogy in the cinema
tomorrow 9:00 last nine hours and ends
at 3:00 a.m. I should probably rest yes
Joel get some sleep
seriously dude I shall make you remember
extreme Ghostbusters see I never really
watched that so don't have any opinions
either way I think that was follow up on
my question I guessed that it was but I
still feel like I don't quite understand
it which would you rather have rewritten
crimes of Grindelwald or the last Jedi
crimes are Grindelwald because I feel
like at least personally I better
understand what crimes of Grindelwald
was trying to do whereas the last Jedi
what it was trying to do just didn't
work for me so like that would have that
that would be more than a rewrite that
would be a complete rebuild from the
ground up which I sure as I don't have
the energy for should the monk return
dr. who would he still be a monk I mean
I would think you'd have to be because
otherwise it's a reference nobody would
get I'd be down for that phasma in your
opinion I'm not onto that ship phasmid
Bosman don't quote me ship names
I don't know ship names worth a day can
you say
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious yes I
can because that's cheating because I
know that word cuz I know the song cuz I
grew up with the movie yeah are we gonna
be able to say that one council of geeks
has a discord I do but it's a patreon
perks
hop on over to the patreon maybe that's
the thought anyways I gotta hop on over
there
um so let me see what the questions were
over you okay I'm alright I am fine I am
with it I am awesome I'm not awesome but
okay which do you find more annoying in
which you find funnier nice guys are
nice girls trying to sort that question
on my head um they're both capitalized
so I feel like they're in reference to
something that I don't quite follow I
mean if it is what I think it is no I
can't sort that out in my head I can't I
can't parse that question I'm sorry
should have done this before I had as
many drinks as I did where in the world
would you most like to visit that you
haven't yet Ireland yeah yeah definitely
what is the most overused trope in
science fiction um I don't know if is
the most overused but the one that says
to bug me the most is the primitive
culture viewing the interstellar
travelers as gods not a fan of that one
especially considering that like you
even look at primitive cultures on this
planet we tend to we tend to depict like
ancient Rome or the Celts or whatever as
like really firmly believing that the
gods were real but like all evidence
indicates that they thought of gods you
know Zeus Poseidon Hades etc the same
way mo the majority of people in modern
culture think of God in a nebulous
Christian context which is yeah I kind
of believe but not like a hard core that
dictates every aspect of my life
so that
I don't know if it's the most overused
but it's the one I'm the sickest of oh
I'm okay
what made you fall in love with Star
Wars Harry Potter Doctor Who whatever
well Star Wars like I said I've little
literally always had Star Wars in my
life mm-hmm I don't remember not having
Star Wars in my life so I couldn't even
tell you uh Harry Potter just curiosity
because I knew it was a big thing and I
was like I suppose I should check this
out and I read the first book I'm like
that was really good and then I kept
with it just really straightforward I
didn't I didn't read the first the
fourth book had cut had come out by the
time I started reading them so that was
the point at which I jumped on Doctor
Who if I were to narrow down to one
thing it was the nude I was channel
surfing in London on my honeymoon saw
nude stopped because it reminded me of a
mind flayer for Dungeons and Dragons
because that's how big a frigging geek I
am and it was the Satan pin it was the
last 20 minutes half hour or so of the
Satan pit I'm like I gotta watch the
rest of this so as soon as I was back in
the States on Netflix on Netflix DVD had
thing had the things sent to me caught
up through the first three series
started watching it as it airs starting
with series four would you rather read
something or watch something Dadd nature
of me says watch something because I get
more out of less time commitment as I
say I don't enjoy reading
I just just I need to break from it more
readily if you had one wish except
wishing forward I have infinite wishes
what would it be and what would you do
to come to a conclusion for the best
possible wish Oh best possible wish is
easy
I've known this one for a long time I
would wish that any time I had to
purchase anything I could reach into my
pocket and pull out exact change
stopping off for copy for coffee
exact change having lunch exact change
buying a house exact change
new car exact change I just reach in my
pocket and there was a fine from the IRS
because I can't account for where my
income is coming from exact change
so that would be our one wish have you
ever considered writing your own fantasy
sci-fi novel
not only have I considered it I've done
it hoping to publish it next year dream
is a fire watch for that uh what is the
airspeed velocity of an unladen Sparrow
it depends if it's African or European
and you have just been flung off the
bridge by friends uh as you put five to
six as your top regeneration Oh shout
out to the latest video no not latest
video but read a recent video did you
finally get Davis's doctor in that
moment maybe not over the whole of his
regeneration but at least in that story
honestly no I still don't get him but I
can still recognize separate from my
inability to get five as a doctor I can
still recognize that that transition and
the reason for in his decision in that
moment that caused the regeneration is
friggin perfect um I noticed in the
background of your videos you have that
mmm you have the pop of the curb lamb
man where did you get it
it was it was gifted to me it was sent
to me I cannot remember by whom but this
this was gifted to me and was then
dutifully put upon this shelf oh I I'm
gonna have to backtrack once I'm done
with the discord to see if I missed any
stupid chat oh boy okay um let's see
kind of a ramble about missing the
stream oh wait the latch thing hey kid
you did good to see you here TV and said
um not sure if it can me if I can make
the live show encased on have a
wonderful holiday and an awesome mayor
sweet because yeah mmm that's worth
pointing out this is the last live
stream of the year which is also a part
of them also
part of the reason that I'm willing to
get friggin sloshed doing it because the
next two Tuesday's it's Christmas Eve
and then it's New Years Eve and yeah I
have other plans cuz I do have something
vaguely resembling a life plus you know
family so this is gonna be the last one
for the year I'm almost at the one hour
mark so I guess this one's running long
I'm having fun
hope you are too getting back to the
discord if you had a TARDIS ting could
go anywhere where would you go I
honestly don't know ah I did think I'd
have already made answer for that but I
really don't because one of those cases
where literally the entirety of time and
space opens up to me and I kind of
freeze up and like I don't know you tell
me I can go anywhere and suddenly I just
I have no ideas do you think there
should be any taboos for satire oh boy
this is a this is a question that I
shouldn't I shouldn't be trying to
answer when not sober but here we go
do you think there are any taboos for
satire I think there was someone was a
Charlie Chaplin who said that you can
disperse a lot of things with laughter
however in Germany no one sane would
ever make a joke about the genocide at
least as far as I know I will refer you
to the video I made a few months ago on
who's allowed to tell what joke even
though the question you're asking is
slightly different my answer is very
much the same which is my answer is any
topic is fair game but not any target is
fair game so to use the example of
Germany and making jokes about the
genocide you can make a joke
theoretically I don't have one ready as
an example so don't ask but you could
make a joke about the genocide so long
as the punchline is not the victims of
the genocide if your punchline
is the Nazis I don't think anyone's
gonna object to you taking a shot at the
Nazis well some people might somebody
will legitimately say you shouldn't joke
about that regardless but I will say I I
will stand by my stance that no topic is
off-limits some targets should be
off-limits especially depending on who
the joke teller is because context
matters people want the nice clean
answer of either this thing's okay to
joke about or it or it isn't but that
tries to ignore context in context
dictates everything because who is
telling the joke in the situation the
circumstances under which they're
telling the joke make or break the
entire thing every single time oh I
can't believe I've only been with the
council one year huh last year's
holidays times when I started watching
oh cool what room do you film in I film
in my bedroom my bed is right there my
desk that I edited that edit at is right
there and no I'm not gonna turn this
around to show you because this room is
up Reagan disaster and I have a little
too much self-respect oh what's your
biggest pet peeve people who after I
introduced myself and say hi my name is
Nathaniel go hi Nate I wonder if akame
Nader would have introduced myself as
Nate I didn't that one just pisses me
off
um not exactly about the genocide but
look at the Fawlty Towers episode the
Germans great example the Germans okay
I'm off to discord him back to the main
thing hello I'm back yay
I don't think I missed any super chats
somebody tell me if I did so I don't I
don't have to scroll all the way up
through if I don't need to um holy crap
is it weird I love with Americans say
Doctor Who bloody love your guys's
accent really do people love the
American Acts
is that a thing like that's weird
especially for me because I have a very
neutral accent or at least I think I do
like the most pronounced accents in
America are like southern or Minnesota
or you know California surfer New York
Boston I mean there is a Vermont accent
I don't have it because by the time I
moved here I was already five years old
and like the formative years of my
accent building were kind of behind me
so I like I have an American accent I
accept that but I don't think I haven't
especially region to find one I think it
with you I picked up living in Vermont
is I picked up the yup because that
rather than saying yes that is a kind of
a Vermont thing well it's kind of an
upper New England thing you get it a
little bit northern Hampshire you get it
in Maine but yep yep nope I suppose it's
the equivalent of Hot Fuzz and the
Europe remember villages remember the
legends of tomorrow met PT Barnum and it
was a good episode and pretty accurate
while more toned-down that's true and
that was Billy Zane too wasn't it he's
always a good get why aren't more people
hiring Billy Zane I'd hire Billy Zane to
be on this podcast if I could afford him
I should find out what it's going rate
is maybe I can't afford him mm-hmm
I probably know the answer but would you
rather have the eighth doctor back for a
live-action spinoff series or Omega back
for an episode also what are your hopes
for season 12 hopes for season 12 is
likely to be a an episode topic so I'm
not gonna answer that I would rather
have Omega back because I feel like
having the eighth doctor back in a
competing parallel show just invites
comparison and competition and I'm not
sure that's what the fandom needs right
now
oh 13s new nickname from me northern
blondie
haha wait till they hear my voice see I
just I just read that and I immediately
heard it in my head as Jack Nicholson's
Joker well they get a load of me
I almost called you Nate in the comment
I left on the video you did talking
about your book in the number-two author
diary well good thing you didn't my
friend do you or have you ever watched
the youtuber Vsauce no I literally only
know them because folding ideas did a
video on that channel that's the only
reason I've even heard of them not
forgetting narf yes of course narf
I get what you didn't like Tennant's I
didn't want to go line but I think the
war doctor retcon and making him the
form before the last made it less
problematic I'm not sure I follow I
guess I'm not I'm not entirely sure how
inserting the war doctor impacts the
regeneration of 10:00 to 11:00 I'm not
there's a connection you've made there
that I'm not making would you ever write
a doctor who now would know right would
you ever write a Doctor Who novel
published on at the BBC if they're
willing to pay me hell yes almost swore
um of course but I like seriously you
you folks didn't understand this while I
do have some degree of standards and I'm
not gonna say I'm for sale to anybody I
am very much for sale if somebody wants
to pay me to write something pay me to
write a script pay me to write a concept
a spec whatever if the money is there I
will do it and happily like it's not
like I'm jus good for money no I'll take
the money like again not from anybody
and not for anything but I am for sale I
am NOT going to pretend otherwise
according to us subtitles Jodie
Whittaker comes from hoods and field
instead of Huddersfield I'm not even
gonna try read that with an axe thing
because it would just be insulting to
everybody
ah did you did you you said you never
gave your daughter to talk about your
gender since it's so normalized with her
what would you do when she experiences
contrary sentiment sorry gender fluidity
spectrum unsure what to call it
um I mean if she ever if she ever
expresses to me a confusion or
questioning either about me or about
herself how what will I do I'll sit down
and talk to her figure out where her
heads at and figure out what I can do to
help help her better understand herself
or me whatever's that question I mean
that's all that you can do as a parent
and with anything the quickest way to
drive yourself crazy as a parent is to
try and imagine what you would do for
every possible scenario cuz he can't
account for everything and if you think
you can the instant something happens
that you didn't account for your world
crumbles I'll deal with it as it comes
when it comes up how I'll deal with it
will depend entirely on the
circumstances under which it happens and
if it ever does I probably won't talk
about it here because that'll end up
being a personal moment between me and
her so there you go this freeze on me
okay cool
where did you get the derek jacobi
screwdriver from I don't I don't have
one you're referring to something that I
don't know what it is I mean I've got
I've got a typical screwdrivers cuz I've
got like the build-your-own that I've
currently got in this configuration
which could be made into other ones I
feel like this is the popular
configuration of that thing though
because I feel like I've said I've liked
Linkara has it in this configuration
Riley Silverman has it in this
configuration both cool people by the
way never met either one in person but
still okay yeah my chat has definite
because I can see on the phone that I'm
broadcasting from new questions coming
up but they're not coming up for me here
so hang on there we go hey not my doctor
youtuber is going to take you saying I
am for sale as evidence that you're
being paid by the BBC to make good
reviews for Jodie Whittaker I mean I
think the easy counter to that is the
fact that I actually didn't give good
reviews to pretty significant chunks of
Jodie Whitaker's run including Rosa the
most politically progressive episode
like ever so if anybody needs a counter
there you go take me out of context all
you want I'll put it back into context
and you can sit and spin I am
confrontational when I drink life is
interesting my dad grew up in Pittsburgh
which is a very distinctive accent you
know I never detected it when I was
growing up yeah it's funny how that
works
I love 13s reaction to a regeneration
what did you think she was thinking when
she saw her new reflection they she was
the oh bloody hell I've gone northern I
don't know what she was thinking um it
was kind of cool to have her be happy
with it though
because the initial reaction to the
regeneration excuse me for the modern
era up to that point you know nine to
ten new teeth it's weird and you know
eleven the chin blimey
still not ginger you know criticizing
and then eleven to twelve I've got new
kidneys I don't like the color
you know largely critical or like
skeptical it was kind of nice that
thirteen was like oh I dig it
cool um you know of course obviously
some people read into that like oh it's
saying that women are better but no it's
only saying about if you project that on
so I mean either because you believe
that or you want to believe that the BBC
is saying that so you can be angry about
it but there you go got a go getting
laid here congrats on the milestone and
have a happy Christmas in newett Thank
You Cara thank you very much
I gotta have you clarify for me one of
these whether it's Cara or Cara cuz I
have a friend named Cara and my kid has
a parakeet named Cara and I don't know
which you pronounce it as and you've
probably even specified before cuz I
feel like I brought this up before and
either don't remember didn't notice if
you answered that is my life okay um I
mean the eleventh Doctor was revealed to
be his 12th and final regeneration then
that ends the doctor dies for good and
that's why ten was being emotional um I
um I don't I feel like a stretch to me
you're trying to use reality on those
people they don't accept that well I
don't have to accept people who don't
accept reality there we go we got one
just mutually ignore each other
everybody's happy or everybody's met or
had or everyone's happy with the reason
that they're mad there you go
if you want a good moment in family guy
would recommend the moment where Ida
talked about her struggle
I haven't rewatched the Ida episodes
that I've seen in a long time and I and
I haven't watched
Family Guy for a while so I don't know
if she's come back so I don't feel in a
position to speak one way or the other
on that I will say that my mixed
feelings overall about what I remember
being Ida's depiction but like I said
it's been a while I have a watch family
gone a long time I can highly recommend
the Watchmen HBO series though warning
in the comment sections is probably
gonna need a lot of cleaning you'll know
why just from the first episode I
actually had a co-worker really strongly
recommend that today maybe yesterday I
was yesterday yesterday he really
strongly recommended that to me
and I would like to see it it's a matter
of carving out time I would have made
time before if I'd had more people
asking the thing is like literally two
people have asked me since it started
airing so I was like oh okay so it's not
like in high demand for my subscribers
which bumped it down the priority list
uh it's karak cool haha I pretty much
answer anything no but I want to know I
want to know like how I get up and even
when people shorten the thing today I
want to know how you prefer your name to
be pronounced Cara awesome I feel better
now now that I know that Cheers
I should mention there's also alcohol in
this oh dear what's your favorite
episode of each classic era doctor so
far okay bearing in mind then I still
have a bit of a ways to go to catch up
on all of clásico so bearing that in
mind Dalek invasion of Earth tombs of
the Cybermen time warrior city of death
caves of Androzani vengeance on Varro's
remembrance of the Daleks night of the
doctor
there you go do we count eight as
classic though because he's kind of a
weird anomaly that happened between the
end of the classic era and the start of
the new era I guess by default we put
him in classic but really I feel like
he's kind of his own thing
almost separate from everything else I
think you're I think in your doctor
regeneration ranked video you could have
included the cause of death for all I
know you said about six but not for the
others
um I mean the thing was the cause of
death wasn't a major factor and a lot of
the decisions because that kind of tied
it in a bit more into what the narrative
up to that point had been especially
with something like say planet of the
spiders if I'd factored in cause of
death that would have liked say for
instance brought that one down it also
probably would have put lakopolous even
further down cuz I'm not a fan of that
episode like at all even aside from the
wonkiness with the larger if you were
dr. Manhattan you could see every
episode of the exact same time ah yes
but then I'd also be in a loop prick
scratch that already am I guess ain't
counts as the paradigm shift doctor ah I
feel more like eight counts as the just
anomaly doctor because he didn't kick
off anything new but he was so far
removed from what had come before that
you can't count him as the old it's just
a blip on the radar and I say that
liking the Eighth Doctor our classic
Doctor Who episode request patreon
exclusive like TV episodes and stuff no
ok so classic episode reviews right now
or on the podcast feed so you need to
search for the Council of geeks podcast
that's where classic Hoover views are
right now which episode I review that is
a patreon vote to cuz I'll narrow it
down to three
and then the patrons supporters will
vote but the reviews there are or on the
podcast I'm not gonna say how are you
look Oh God
I'm not gonna say how regular Larry they
go up because I've been really
inconsistent about that but those are
those are publicly available I don't I
don't plug the podcast for you largely
because I'm so inconsistent updating on
it um so you've made sure you've already
got your paycheck for your serious well
version from the BBC ha ha ha
dubenko's already got his it's been
stolen by the living flesh supercomputer
well that's why Stu bankfull is always
so bitter because the BBC cuts him his
his bribery check to ensure that he
reviews kindly all the new Doctor Who
episodes but then that money gets stolen
by the living flesh supercomputer and
then he gets bitter and that's why he's
so grumpy in the reviews see we've
sorted it out we got it figured what
sonic screwdriver designed you like the
most it depends if you mean on the show
or as a toy cuz that's a toy as a
reproduction I'm rather fond of 12 but
the thing is 12 looks too much like a
toy on the show that I don't really love
it all that much um
despite the fact that it was often waved
around like a magic wand a little too
much you probably like Elevens the best
going back to God in science fiction I'm
being biased but I don't think that the
actual Abrahamic God should be touched
in Doctor Who less than something like
the presence in the DC Universe I think
would just be better for them to avoid
that question altogether so like it'd
probably be a bad idea to ever have the
doctor encounter like Moses or Abraham
or Jesus Oh God that that would be a a
nightmare uh do you mind being called
Nathan yep yep I do cuz not my name um
do you have a favorite version of a
Christmas carol yes the Muppets
oh oh dear
thoughts on Star Trek personally I'm a
big ds9 fan so I have boy never really
been able to get into the classic series
very well I do like a fair number of the
classic cast original Star Trek cast
movies I like Wrath of Khan though not
as much as a lot of Star Trek fans do I
love voyage home because I grew up on
that I'd like undiscovered country I
like first contact I actually even like
the reboot and into darkness and beyond
to varying degrees
I'm more than anything I am a
next-generation person though because
that's him there are a number of shows
and I haven't talked about this on here
but I've top hold on uh who I haven't
talked about on this here but I
mentioned it when I appeared on cheers
cast with Ryan Daly who's the one in the
logo holding the lightsaber um because
he has a podcast which is very good and
folks should check out I can plug people
besides myself yay um where he's going
through every single episode of Cheers
with a guest and um you know we're
talking about it and I I was on it for a
season one episode and I got to tell him
this but I don't think I've ever said it
here there are a number of shows that in
my head
get cataloged as my grandfather's shows
because I would when I was younger
through about eighth grade actually I
would spend summers with my grandparents
cuz I went to a camp that was a short
walk from their house but then obviously
on you know he
in the weekends I was back with them so
there were a number of shows that my
grandfather watched that I in my memory
I think of as his shows and mash was one
Cheers was one Seinfeld was one and Star
Trek The Next Generation was one and
Star Trek The Next Generation was the
only one that I would actually sit down
wit and watch with him I would kind of
float in and out of the others sometimes
I've watched him sometimes I wouldn't
but Star Trek The Next Generation is
probably always gonna be my go-to even
if I feel like another series is better
because I have the nostalgic link to
that it connects me to those summers my
grandparents it connects me to my
grandfather and my boat my grandparents
have passed on at this point and I can
think back to that time and he'd be in
his chair I said his chair you know in
TV was in the living room there was a
couch there were two chairs but there
was a chair that was his chair he'd be
in his chair and I'd be on the floor on
my stomach doing this watching Star Trek
The Next Generation and I don't think no
matter how good any new series might be
I don't think anything can compete with
the nostalgia of that for me so there
you go by the way I saw a Funko pop of
norm today and thought of you
norm I saw George Wendt on Broadway in
Hairspray
playing Edna
he was so good it was amazing Nathaniel
I loved series 12 the BBC all these bags
of money look honestly so like two
things
yeah if like this and I said I have said
this and I will reiterate it if I ever
get approached by the BBC by Disney by
Marvel by anybody saying here's money
review our thing positively you have my
pledge that what I will do instead is an
expose on this channel about how they
tried to bribe me for a review because I
cannot imagine that they would ever
offer me enough money that I wouldn't
just do that because I could be a
mercenary bugger and if I had an email
chain a recorded phone call any evidence
which I would have to have cuz they're
not gonna show up at my door then I had
been offered to be paid off for a
positive review I would get way more
pressed way more views way more
everything just by going public with it
because if they could offer me more
money than I would make doing that then
it that that just wouldn't happen
because it would not make any financial
sense cuz that's the amount of money
that I have to offer to everybody that
they quote unquote bribe for the good
reviews and that's a sync that's a money
sinkhole cuz like I'm not necessarily
gonna put a dollar value on it but if
somebody wanted to pay me for a review
and guarantee a positive review they
would have to they would have to offer
me more than I was gonna make in a year
minimum and if they were offering that
to every every critic that they that
supposedly gets bribed they would have
doubled the budget of any one of these
things and there's no friggin way
especially considering all those BBC
bribes come from from us license fee
payers yes thank you mister L for your
contribution to the Council of geeks as
your license fee has paid for my bribe
to positively review a series 11 which I
didn't do so I guess I owe the BBC their
money back Oh what was the most stupid
silly thing you ever did while being
wasted on water uh now you're never
gonna be bribe the BBC is watching
dammit that they don't watch the live
streams stupidest thing I ever did while
being wasted on the water um see I I
actually know the answer but I'm not I'm
not gonna tell you because it involves
other people and I don't I really make a
point of only sharing my own story if I
feel like something that I have to say
is somebody else's story it's not my
place to share it even if like they only
have 50 percent so I know what the
answer to that question is and I'm not
going to answer it uh imagine Doctor Who
and Jumanji crossover I still need to
see the new Jumanji stuff I saw haven't
seen welcome to the jungle I've been
meaning to for freakin ages now um I've
seen the YouTube video Joker versus
penny wise if you do watch it just know
some of the humor is pretty more but no
I haven't seen it if you've seen enough
versions and would have the time to do
so would you want to do a ranking of a
Christmas carol adaptation
um so that's the kind of thing that like
at least in my head no promise this cuz
I don't want to let people down but in
my head that's the kind of thing that
like maybe I could do if this was my
full-time gig if this was how I paid my
bills but since it's not um I just I
just don't think I have the time because
the thing is like theoretically if I
didn't have to hold down a 40 hour week
job that is in theory 40 hours a week
that I could devote to this and bigger
projects like watching every version of
a Christmas carol and then ranking the
suckers in reality what I would probably
be gaining would be let me think for a
minute I'd probably be gaining between
20 and 30 hours a week because the
amount of time that I currently spend on
the channel which happens between when I
get home and when I go to bed um ranges
from 10 to 20 hours a week so if I just
shift that to a daytime job of 40 hours
a week and I I don't have if I didn't
have to do my day job anymore that means
I add about 20 hours so I wouldn't
actually add as much time as you would I
don't actually just get to add 40 hours
to my week um because I would like to
think that I could stop at say five if I
was doing this as my actual day job but
I still think that would be enough time
to be able to consider you know doing
longer you know bigger more expansive
more viewing hours more research
projects like that I mean that's the guy
that's the kind of stuff that I really
hope to do more of if and it is an if I
wish I could say when but I can't
guarantee that but if I ever get to the
point where I can safely leave my day
job and have this pay my bills that is
the kind of stuff that I want to spend
more time doing
but will I ever get there I have no idea
uh when do you think the doctor will be
played by a person of color actor or an
actress who would you pick I like I did
my picks for who I think would be good
actress for the doctor there's a whole
video on that so you can check that when
will it happen I have no idea um I
didn't think that Graham Brandon yaz
will leave the TARDIS team I'm still
sticking to my prediction that Graham's
gonna die I was fully expecting it to
happen in series 11 it didn't I still
think that's how he leaves the rest of
them I don't know why shake this blue
doll like off the shelf it was beautiful
because it wasn't actually mine it was
my daughter's and she asked for her back
that's why it's just me or a sci-fi
comedy and underrated genre mix it
doesn't happen a lot but when it does
it's great things like Hitchhiker's
Guide in the good place I think the
thing was sci-fi comedy is that by its
nature if you're gonna do anything with
a sci-fi bent whether it's sci-fi comedy
are just straight sci-fi doing sci-fi
well is expensive because you're either
paying for a lot of practical effects
and makeup or you're paying for a lot of
CGI or you're paying for both and comedy
by large comedies need to be cheap
because you know you're banking on a
certain type of humor to land it to
carry the whole thing and if it doesn't
well then you're not gonna get your
money back and comedies are honestly a
bit more of a dice roll than most genres
because if it's not funny it doesn't
play and I think because they are a bit
more of of a dice roll in that way
Studios don't want to throw a ton of
money at comedies like even comedies
with really big name actors they don't
also have a ton of special effects so
you know comedies
about a comedy's top out on the cheap
side for the most part whereas sci-fi
done well can't really be done cheap or
it takes a really razor-sharp production
plan to make a site a good-looking
sci-fi movie on the cheap so unless your
joke is this looks like crap and these
effects don't look convincing the sci-fi
comedy is gonna be way more money than
most studios or networks or whatever
want to spend on a comedy when they do
if it works
it's amazing they're like the two can
definitely go together as far as general
genres and mashing together goes but
it's it's an issue of the expense how
would you rank the regenerations of
curse of fatal death dr. oh god I don't
know I don't even like that thing that
much red dwarf does a great job looking
cheap red dwarf does but then again red
dwarf part of the well two things one is
as a BBC production especially starting
as it did in the 80s the expectation
wasn't that it would look good in the
first place because it was a BBC
production it wasn't really competing
with say Star Trek it was competing with
how people remember Doctor Who which
meant it could afford to look cheap and
be fine so red dwarf is kind of a bit of
an exception and if you're gonna make
the cheap effects part of the humor you
can work that but that does limit the
kind of comedy you can make up uh what
new who villain would you want to return
mr. fynch always always always always
always this includes the classic
villains that have come back and new
who's still mr. fynch anthony Stewart
head bring him back how do you think the
doctor will get stuck in Paris 1943 and
spy fall part ones bifold out to spy
fall dart to part two I can speak
I'm not drunk that's a lie and I have no
idea how do you get people to give you
honest criticism people who have read my
script have said that it was good so I
know that it's what a strong points are
but I want to know is weak points
um I mean that the thing is you get all
you can do anytime you present anyone a
piece of your creative work and want
honest feedback all you can do is say
please give me your honest opinion and
trust that they are doing that is it
possible that some of them still give
you positive and ignore maybe negative
criticisms that they have for the sake
of being nice yes that's possible but
the thing is you start second-guessing
that and you're undermining the entire
process and also creatives have a
inherent instinctive point that we tend
to put more stock in negative criticisms
than we do in positive because we can
have a thousand people say what we did
was great and one person say that it
sucks and we will put more weight in
that one person because there's this
weird belief and I say weird as if I
don't have it but I do it if it impacts
me to that negative criticism is somehow
more honest and that's not true but we
think it's true and so when somebody
comes back with the only good notes
we second-guess that and we think what
aren't they telling me and then when
somebody comes in and tells us all the
ways in which we suck we think there's
the honest person because unless you've
got an ego the size of the friggin
county I live in then you tend to assume
that you suck and you're kind of looking
for confirmation of that
and while it's not necessarily a good
thing to end up with an ego so big that
it is legitimately ironclad you've got
to be careful of falling into the trap
of thinking that only negative feedback
is honest Roxie Williams are ou not
right
my vision is blurred that's a bad sign
Rory Williams or rip hunter ah taken as
individuals rip hunter that said I would
prefer Rory so long as he is paired with
Amy but if I am taking them solely as
individuals I would prefer Brent
that's why I tried to provide positive
and negative points I know Carolyn and
you're really good with that in case
anyone was wondering Carolyn is one of
the folks who has beta read my book and
her feedback has been incredibly helpful
so I saw the Big Finish Tenth Doctor
adventures vol 1 are on audible been
wanting to get those for a while I saw
the list I haven't listened to any of
the temp doctor's stuff any of the Tenth
Doctor Big Finish stuff my words are now
legitimately starting to slur and I need
to end this soon and for the sake of
everybody favorite Batman and favorite
Bruce Wayne Oh favorite Bruce Wayne is
Michael Keaton favorite Batman um
favorite Batman is oh god what's his
name um
the guy who played Robocop because he
voiced Batman for legends of the Dark
Knight Peter Weller ha ha Oh
Tracy oh you do this to me why do you
think Constantine works well legends but
the solo film didn't
do well I know the exact reason the
problem with the Constantine's
solo series was not the character
because the character was done perfectly
well the issue was the structure of the
Constantine TV show was anywhere from
five to ten years out of date because it
was very much based around the structure
of the case of the week it was
structured in the way the early series
of the Buffy were structured it was
structured the way house was structured
it was a tired formula by the time
Constantine started doing it and I know
some people are gonna say well as easily
was supernatural does but the thing is
Supernatural started doing it when it
was still fresh and then built a fan
base and kept doing it for friggin what
1415 years however long it went on but
Constantine tried to come in after that
formula the monster-of-the-week formula
or just the problem of the week you know
cuz like I said house did the same
friggin thing and that formula was tired
it was a formula from anywhere from five
to ten years ago that they tried to make
work and it didn't and not cuz it was
bad because it was predictable because
it was tired
whereas legends is freaking nuts and
whatever you think about whether you
like it or you don't it's not
predictable a little bit splashed out
onto my hand there so whatever you think
of legends legends is not predictable
and holy crap I'm an idiot
this was a horrible idea and by which I
mean it was the best idea so he slots
into that so much better because it is a
much more freeform easygoing freely
adaptable and valuable template that is
used for legends they can do so much
more and go in so many different
directions and he just slots in there so
easily
that's it
haha I'm done no more no more drinks no
more shots I am finished also what do
you think of the cause of team in
Justice League action I actually haven't
gotten to any of it justice league
action episodes with a minute I've only
seen a couple justice league action
pisode oh I got it my eyes bloodshot oh
ah I've got to go helping my mum early
tomorrow thank you adding to my year
with these live streams I have a Merry
Christmas in New Year and for God's sake
stay out of blank you look sloshed yeah
I'm done at this point even if I get
even if I get more more super chats at
five dollars or more
I'm done I'm done drinking I'll stick
with the live stream for a little bit
longer but yeah no more shots that that
was oh man that was it uh how many movie
I'd recommend walk hardwood Dewey Cox
huh I just don't like that troop I'm
classy of comics I don't really like
Will Ferrell I don't like Adam okay I
don't like anchorman I just don't like
that style of comedy will you ever rank
your favorite episode of each doctor
against each other a type of battle
royale to determine to determine best
your favorite episode possibly when I
have seen more from classic era
I'm gonna give myself a hard cutoff at
nine
I guess that point I should just lay
down and drink water like real water
holy crap uh I drink I'm the demon think
you should show up in the air overs yes
I'm actually kind of surprised he hasn't
shown up yet now that I think of it on
legends especially I put most stock in
mixed feedback even if you love or hate
something that's rare to have no small
pluses or nitpicks whatsoever that's
fair you had that's a pretty fair
assessment I think this is the first
ever time I've seen you belch you gonna
ask Liz I do it plenty I just try and
hold it back you seen past fun drunk I
think I'm on the outer edge of fun drunk
which is why I'm stopping anymore and I
would tip over the edge and it'd be bad
and that I would be what Liz and I term
Queen in the north drunk and there is a
story behind that but not my story to
share if you watched Umbrella Academy I
think you could do a great review series
um I did watch it the thing the reason I
didn't do a review on it was because by
the time I watched it it wasn't really
current anymore it was it like had been
out for a month um if I get through the
second season in a more timely manner I
might do a review on that um but that
was why I didn't do a review on the
first season other than hell-bent is
there any Doctor Who episode you'll
never watch again worries the deep fear
or the Crimson horror killed the moon no
and I don't even watch how bent again
cuz I would like to find something to
praise about even the episodes that
aren't good what is your opinion on
crisis on Infinite Earths so far don't
have one haven't seen
too much movement with the hands
alcoholic smaller youtuber Kells himself
on stream uh that would be quite the
headline wouldn't it I suppose it's not
a good idea that I've got a rack of
weapons right behind me Queen in the
north that's right when did you first
get drunk I didn't I was probably out of
in nineteen forty ever got drunk because
I was a I was a lame ass in high school
and I never gotten invited to the
parties where there was alcohol so I
didn't have my first drink until I was
in college
so I would have been either eighteen or
nineteen first time I got drunk um cuz I
said I just it didn't happen in high
school didn't happen till I got to
college
of course technically speaking legally I
shouldn't have been drinking and then
should wait till I was 21 I didn't who
does let's be real
that's not me encouraging drinking under
21 I don't encourage that at all cuz
actually even at the time I remember my
first time getting drunk I'm like I
don't love this um so actually I kinda I
didn't like hard stop drinking but I
didn't drink I never I was never a binge
drinker drinking to get drunk has never
been a thing that I've really done since
you've seen Umbrella Academy already
what were your thoughts I liked it for
the most part um I mix thoughts about
Vanya 'he's trajectory as a oh god why
did I do that motion that that was meant
to be like a showing a trajectory Oh God
moving on my mixed feelings about her
trajectory as a character because I
think she's actually more interesting as
what she was originally presented to be
which is the one person with no powers
and the family of all superpower people
I suppose I think she was eventually
revealed to be I find that less
interesting but short of that I liked it
pretty well I really liked
five-five was great have you been
watching his Dark Materials not as
they've aired but I do need to watch the
first four episodes because I have been
commissioned to review them so that's
coming I was 12 when I first had wine
maybe 11 seemed like I tasted beer at UH
how old I was maybe 10 I thought it was
the most disgusting thing I've ever
tasted and my opinion of beer has really
not changed so do you think the new gods
will show up in Supergirl post-crisis um
maybe it's hard to tell and here's the
reason why it's very obvious that at
least at some point in the previous past
Warner Brothers had carved out the New
Gods to be a DC movies thing because
obviously they were they were gonna use
Darkseid if nobody else and the DC
movies already have a history of
whatever they plan to use in the movies
they don't want to show up in the TV
shows it's why there was a setup for the
Suicide Squad in arrow even though the
Suicide Squad was never allowed to
happen because they decided that was
gonna be a movie and so it was set up
and never paid off in arrow so I know at
one point New Gods were definitely gonna
be a DC movies thing at this point
enough things as shuffled around that
maybe that's not the case anymore and
also maybe they're not as stringent
about ensuring that these things are
kept so separate as they used to be but
even setting that aside my inclination
is that the expense of realizing the New
Gods decently at all would be more than
a TV budget could reasonably be expected
to pull off cuz Kirby's ideas were many
things but his vision was not cheap to
realize in any medium of than that other
than illustration I've never been
invited to a party where there was
alcohol I neither confirm nor deny
whether or not
ever been drunk wise person you are good
sir
every roll ever watch the show called
Ruby if so what are your thoughts on I
have not I'm well aware of it because
it's hard to not be at least aware of it
but no I've never seen it I am gonna
wrap this up soon I think I get nine
nines a good stopping time
oh stop at night it'll be a big
celebration to our end of the year a
weird thing to ask I saw this Instagram
poll and now I'm wondering do you think
the ladies do you think time ladies get
periods do you think 13 would get her
period personally I don't think um my
inclination is going to be no um I am
resting my leg on the foot of my bed
right now I don't know why I felt I need
to tell you that my inclination is no
because unless an or until doctor who
decides to contradict to it time laws
don't reproduce sexually they have the
freaking Loom thing which is still canon
until it's not but even if they decide
that the Loom is not canon that doesn't
automatically mean that Time Lord
physiology works the same as human
because there's no reason to believe
that I would so my my inclination by
large is to say no let's see
we're not going to eleventh hour of end
disappointed
I'm sorry DB like uh I've got my limits
as the year comes to a close I want to
personally thank you for the hell-bent
grant officially one of my favorite
videos of yours to rewatch this is my
official favorite channel oh yeah Wow
crap
thank you John Wow huh Ruby is great
I've heard good things but I'm also I'm
like anime shows don't hook me all that
often I'm much more inclined towards
anime movies than I am shows looms are a
hotly debated topic yeah that's true do
you think that 21 is too high for a
legal drinking age um I don't know
because I've never actually looked into
the um whether or not there's a
scientifically based or research-based
reason for it to be 21 as opposed to 18
so ever gonna review the error --air
over shows probably not cuz they only
want to watch his legends of tomorrow
and I don't watch it as it airs i binge
it over the summer after it's done so
unlikely Thank You Clara
so um I'm not gonna take a drink for
that one cuz I'm done Congrats on
congrats on 40,000 subs if you could
experience any film TV series for the
first time again what would it be um wow
that is a good question if I could
especially for a first time
honestly I'm gonna go TV but not TV
series specific episode of TV
I would love to rewatch black mirror
Sanjana pero for the first time that'd
be really nice to feel that joy in that
connection again as far as a film goes I
think probably shape of water for a very
similar reason I Liz would back me up on
this if she was here I cried two or
three times watching shape of water
because of the connection that has made
between the lead character and the River
God and her love of him regardless of
anything else and the line that she has
saying that he doesn't know that I'm
incomplete the power of her feeling a
connection with someone who doesn't see
her as wrong or broken not even like
overlooking a fault of her inability to
speak
but just doesn't doesn't see that it's
even something to be viewed as wrong he
just doesn't know as she says that she's
incomplete that hit me so hard and I
loved that movie and it it really made
my night when I won Best Picture
because I wanted it to do I didn't think
it would I would really like to go back
and feel that again for the first time
that feeling of being seen by a piece of
entertainment because it took the time
to depict what it feels like to assume
that you will never be accepted fully
for everything you are and then to be to
actually find that acceptance that you
had assumed as a baseline you would
never ever feel
I felt that was Han Junipero and I felt
that with the shape of water and ice
tangent paralyzed on my own but I was so
so happy that I saw shape of water with
Liz
because I at this point my life I feel
embraced and I feel seen and I feel
validated to a degree that I couldn't be
even articulated before because it was
just a background level of presuming
that that would never happen but I'm
sane my partner sees me my daughter sees
me and much as this I have freely met
it's a parasocial relationship I don't
know you folks personally but I do feel
like you see me
to be seen to be validated to be
embraced
ah that's magic
what I get to do is amazing
you folks are amazing people in my
day-to-day life who embrace me who
accept me are amazing and I hadn't
necessarily planned on ending on this no
but I think we're going to guys I don't
know that there's any way for me to
bring him back to the chat in a way that
doesn't feel like it undercuts this
there may have been some really good
questions they came up and I'm sorry
that I don't get to thumb but this means
so much to me this community that has
sprung up around me and what I do I
don't even know how to express how much
it means to me because it's not
something I ever would have thought I
could reasonably have asked for and it's
amazing and you are all amazing and
40,000 subscribers is amazing and
everyone who's on the chat right now is
amazing and everyone who watched this as
an archive video is amazing
I was flipping through a notebook about
a week ago maybe it was a few days ago
remember
I think it was last week and I remember
looking back on entries from years ago
and reading how deeply unhappy I used to
be at one point well not one point but
at points in my past to read that and
not reconnect to it instead to read it
and feel like that's just not who I am
anymore I'm not that deeply unhappy
person anymore
but that is a feeling that I cannot even
begin to express how much it means to me
there's a lot of reasons why I don't
feel that way anymore but the support
and love of you folks of this community
is part of it
it's part of why I don't feel about
myself the way I used to thank you I am
gonna wrap it up there but I really do
mean it when I say that you are
beautiful you are a valid you are loved
because you are the council and I just
run the meetings for as long as you'll
have me have a great holiday whether you
celebrate Christmas or don't have a
great remainder of the year and I will
see you in 2020